في مقطع فيديو يقال انه من العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس مال المنصات وشاغل كل
الليبيين
[موسيقى]
مع المقطع المعلومات المتداوله اللي
شفتوها هي بنت كانت تتمشى على شاطئ البحر
في عز النهار والطريق مو مقطوع ابدا
بالواضح انه رئيسي والسيارات رايحه وجايه
وفجاه وقفت سياره فيها ملثمين اول شيء نزل
واحد لوحده حوالي يركبها في السياره غصب
عنها هي رفضت وحاولت الهرب منه وبعدين نزل
اللي معاه كمان واحد مرتب وحطها فيه او
حطوها في السياره غصب عنها وراحوا وقبل ما
يروحوا واحد منهم نزل من السياره وركب على
ما يبدو انه سياره البنت او سياره تانيه
لهم للملثمين كل هذا والناس بتصور وما حد
قرب بعدها بدات التكهنات والتحليلات
وشيء يقول لا هذا اعتقال مو خطف والفتاه
مخالفه للقانون وغيرها وغيرها من القصص
لكن لغايه الان اللحظه اللي احنا فيها ما
في اي معلومات اكيده عن حقيقه الفيديو او
هويه البنت او الملثمين
[موسيقى]